and thank you very much Gary for doing
this for us I'm super excited it was the
few other we were stories events and I
know this one is going to be the best
yet so totally stuff not yet but it will
never be one better than this that's it
we're done it's uh so cool I want to
actually start I'm gonna ask a few
questions I want to get a little bit
more information nigeria actually
haven't spent too much time chatting him
before so I'm going to start my name is
pretty young and we'll work our way up
and then we'll open up for Q&A there
there was guy really curious you you had
a quote fact i think at somewhere online
but I when you were here so you were out
there actually selling lemonade as other
kids are just still learning how to
squeeze it I'm really curious about sir
you know with your background and coming
over here to the United States a child
how what really drove that sort of
passion for you to really create
something when you were a trivet money
for sprinklers I think yeah I mean I ran
through sprinklers as well likes lemon
slide plenty of other things as well but
you know it's crazy like it goes back to
being five or six years old and trying
to sell stuff you know at some level you
know DNA is one powerful thin and it's
just something that has always been
there I've never filtered the world
without thinking about business that's
just been in my brain you know I've
always thought about how can i sell this
or how come and do that it's just it's
there and so to me it didn't seem weird
to me like when it started snowing I did
not think about building a snowman I was
like looked you know oh I should make a
quick note my sister is literally in
labor right this second so I just want
you to all know how much I'm committed
to commitments because family is my
thing and I'm getting the hell out
usually as I told you the phone I was
going to stay a little longer shake some
hands and kiss some babies but out I got
to go to Jersey and that see
nice hopefully we'll be arriving any
minute but speaking of thank you
speaking of that my sister like it
started snowing and then I would just
look at my sister's face you know as a
team is bored I was like get your
[ __ ] shovel I you know that's like I
just pump when it would snow because I
knew that I was going to shovel
driveways and make cash and you know a
lot of people around me know that I i
don't i'm not obsessed about scale I
like putting in the work I like the dirt
under my fingernails I'm proud of it I
think it matters more than I think we
think I think we're living through a
culture of a lot of smart people right
now especially nurse in our space here
that are very predicated on the math and
the analytics and the efficiencies I
take the bonus prior to caring about
that stuff but I think you need to put
in the work and putting in the work has
been something that's always just come
very naturally I mean we've seen it
through were eager like right after
college she decided to really get your
hands dirty with your parents business
back into these two thousand six you
started the Thunder show which was
amazing for those of you don't know Gary
status and Wine Library TV where he
would rate these wines and have this
unique way of getting even the least
common denominator wine connoisseurs
myself included to sort of understand
somebody need to see here from Istanbul
that was a what that was such an awesome
conference thanks for being here yeah
yeah sorry I [ __ ] told I'm here
slider like it very nice so when they
did that this is a great show we all
looked it but you at one point in his
back into and I may be her biggest
little bit later than that you decided
to stop and stopping almost anything is
really tough you know mental how do you
come to that as an entrepreneur well I
mean it was 2011 I did a thousand
episodes of wine library TV and a month
before I decided I decided three or four
months earlier than five years of five
days a week putting out a 25 minute show
was a good run right they were you know
it's not and I decided that I was gonna
retire and at the last minute maybe
three months you know two months right
before I was going to retire i bought i
started feeling like I was going to let
people down I didn't want to let my but
you know I started reading every comment
started 3 years comments 20 40 comments
per episode saying don't ever stop
people knew that it was like you know
that I was grinding and all of a sudden
when I knew I was going to stop every
time I saw that in the comments section
in her and they like started building
and so I kind of panic and I decided to
start something called daily great for
the people that hear that most thought
let me remember and I decided okay if
I'm gonna stop let me do something new a
shorter form because I was into this
whole micro content thing that
vaynermedia is involved into mobile so
his mobile driven subscription to buy
the great show I tried to make it work
for me it just the decision was done at
that point so I did do 89 episodes of
that as well you know I decided it was
time you know just woke up one morning
in early 2011 I was like said you know I
didn't I'm at this point now where I
feel complete about this part of my
career and journey and there's other
things that we're starting to pull up my
heartstrings and other things that I was
thinking about it you know I've always
knew that it was going to be a chapter I
think for a lot of people even go we
blog posts in 2009 8 when i started
talking about business and
just wine people in America really the
world would love to keep you in your
lane you know there's a lot of people
that said to me why are you talking
about business flying guy stick to Pinot
Grigio [ __ ] you know things like that
and and it was funny to me to think
about it because to me I was always a
businessman before I was the wine guy I
build a very large ecommerce and retail
business long before I ever started that
first episode of wine library TV so it
was fascinating to me that I was happy
that I made that decision because i was
i was getting ridiculous offers to do a
television show the Bravo's of the Food
Network's of the world and they were
very attractive they would have allowed
me to become really famous I would have
made it but I always balked at the
eleventh hour on these deals mainly
because I knew that I would become
America's blind guy if I made that play
and I just do there was other things I
want to talk about and I didn't want to
pigeonhole myself and heck if a fairly
success internet video show made people
feel like they wanted to keep me in that
Lane what would have a hit TV show them
right and so it's kind of what we do
right like it happens that there's like
Tony Soprano camping [ __ ] because we
just can't get him out of her mind as
Tony Soprano and like I just I'm an
entrepreneur first right I'm an
entrepreneur first like I just needed to
be able to talk about those things need
to be involved in those things and it
just felt at the time is right I mean
that makes girls and I personally very
much miss Wine Library TV most of it
goes back we were just out taking all of
the 215 you actually came down about all
the wine and I made a couple really
great friends Evan have a very late
drunk evening but I appreciate that and
I'm glad you doing other things now as
well but one thing is it's 2009 you
started vaynermedia correct and so you
did that with somebody for 26 years now
of your life yes and family matters to
you live it's your brother and I am more
curious about how that relationship
works now that you're working together
every day then how you sort of got to
their account was that change the way
the YouTube interact before I answer
that tremendous question she want to say
that I love Frank Esposito I'm reading a
baby but I'm not reading for it anymore
I'm not going to really interview any
more by reading the board that was the
last guy he's a vino medium flame it's
interesting listen family business how
many people here much romance work in a
family business so you know for the five
or six of you you know there's dynamics
in a family business that are very
different then than any other business
that you could be it with different
partners you know EJ is 11 years younger
than me I would tell you that you know
in some weird way AJ's my first love
right because I was you know he's just
my man and I was like you know 17 16 and
my dad is very very different than i am
and very much a different character he's
the best but he's not kind of the guy
you go to to talk about anything right
it's just yeah just a truth he's old
school he's not he does of amazing
things in many places but emotionally
he's not you know bringing that to the
table and AJ and I because of our age
difference have almost a brother father
kind of thing going on that's very kind
of unique and special we've been we've
we've met so many people that are 11 or
12 or nine or ten years apart and don't
have it we have you know two top I mean
I was out of the house when he was set
it right and so it's just a very unique
thing that we have a very very very
special bond I've been very successful
family businesses because at the end of
the
I love my family more than I love money
there's just really nothing else to end
I [ __ ] mean it like a lot it's easy
to say it people say it but you also
have no the players I've been lucky that
both my dad and my brother don't mind me
being the face or you know I want the
lightly I walking agement I want the
interaction it's the kind of creature I
am both of them a little bit more
introverted differently wired so I spent
a lot of time understanding what makes
them tick what they care about so I
bring that to the table and then you
know then it's been nice that they've
been able to allow me to do what I came
to do it's changed in the fact that you
know a generator running of a company
vaynermedia has gone from 25 to 250
employees in the last 18 months since
I've gotten fully involved and so you
we're running a big company and we're
moving very fast them there's a lot of
Boehner employees in here and they know
they know that like we're running a very
fast entrepreneurial here can we have
our ups and downs and left's and rights
and the unfortunate thing that a lot of
you know is you have to take time to
step out of your business line because
the aging and i only talk about [ __ ] bad
stuff AJ and I only talk about bad stuff
that's what happens when you're a leader
that's what happens when you're running
the ship you're talking about the
problems because you're trying to
address them and we actively try to
figure out ways to celebrate the wins
but it's not in our DNA climbers so
we're worried about the rocks the head
of us the rocks were dealing with right
now we didn't never celebrate enough and
as to what's what's changed is where all
our conversations used to be predicated
on lightly you know we stress about the
jet but you know for the most part it
was pretty lightweight stuff now talking
about very intense stuff very like very
rained into it and it's it's been an
interesting journey with him because I'm
mentoring him before I was kind of the
son of a father and so I'm in a
different place I think it's working
extremely well the thing that a Jedi
have I don't think
dad and I even had is I wouldn't call it
respect but i got i came into my family
business has 21 year old kid and
exploded it I walked in and in four
years took a business 23 to 25 million
dollars so I don't disrespect 21 22 23
24 year olds I understand what you don't
have but I sure know since I just did it
five minutes ago I know what you might
have as well and so I respect hey Jay in
a way that none of my contemporaries
thought i would not in the way that a
lot of my contemporaries thought I
should and and I think it's helped us as
a Jay knows how to coddle like ego and
my wants and like the sanity and you
know I'll do whatever when I make a
decision that I want to do something if
I walked into the office right now and
AJ could taste that I was dead serious
and I said I wanted to bid it to sell
chickens on seventh Avenue keep it like
[ __ ] it let's go and I need that I need
that as it gives me that and I just
think we're we're tremendous partnership
definitely buy them you know it's clear
that you are passionate you care about a
lot of things your family included hence
you family first and and you use it past
the caring about others about the gift
and a curse for you and I'm really
curious about how has it been a curse
like what are the things that really
work to get your been negative because
of it the number one asset in the world
is time and I've given time to so many
things that on paper are difficult to
understand life and in retrospect are
difficult to understand why that's why
you know like I you know I really you
know it's my spring listen I know my
success is predicated on it so I could
never hate on it and I would talk about
me a lot of people here know why am I
will talk a lot about negatives
everybody's got problems I'm
uncomfortable share
line but it's you know as you start
getting more known you know what am I
talking about crushing it every 40
seconds so you try to evolve you know
your conversation and you know after
talking you know I'm a minority I'm an
edge case so after talking about things
that I think other people aren't seeing
and it built up to be fortunate up in a
place where this many people want to
come and see me speak then I started
saying you know what maybe we should
start talking to one or two percent or
three percent that actually do look like
me that you know and and that's been
where some of those things have come out
and I actually appreciate your doing
your homework that's a very good
question you know listen I have a very
tough time staying no I have a very
tough time not trying to over-deliver
even it's for a perfect stranger let
alone an entry level employee I've
employed on his first day or so many
that's in my world you know hi Evan I /
index the things that I / index on like
empathy are why I'm successful but
they're also very difficult to manage
and it's exhausting like you know just
I'm consuming and I'm taking on pressure
from every direction from my two
businesses from my personal brand from
the people that are cynical and have
paid out there for it for for the
concerns I have for everybody my
organization let it not be confused and
there's plenty of vaynor people in here
and they know it's true I'm the head of
HR my head of HR you know that you know
we have a great HR people but I'm like
I'm Michael managing everybody's
emotions to the best of my ability I
forgot that I've gotten older and I've
had a little success of my career so I
think some of the entry-level employees
don't believe it and they're scared to
engage with me but once they do they're
surprised and so you know I consume
emotion at scale and and that can be
daunting at times you clearly worked on
many many things and one that sort of
leucine
few years as you become quite the active
investor a number of very interesting
companies including tumblr who was
recently acquired and also registry one
of my personal favorites right now got
some great products but I'm really
curious about where do you see the next
kind of for you and investments if it's
a tech not of the next like three to
five years maybe you provide to 10 where
is the Easter your focus and that
changing what's exciting you the most
I'm starting to really consider some
sort of funded vehicle you know I don't
want to be the cliche guy and start a
fund but man it's some you know listen
I'm going to be very honest with all of
you guys like I always have I suck it so
much it's not even funny but boy do I
intuition and when you have intuition
when it comes to business it could be
very profitable and very very successful
and you know when I look at the exits
that I've achieved with you know early
Facebook that it'll buy facebook stock
from such as parents buying the
Twitter's first see to you when he was
exiting his stock and wait via tumblr in
the phone I'm you know buddy media
wildfire and you know I mean when I
think about that I I don't have a lot of
liquid to invest have always been my
personal money and when I think about my
God if I had a vehicle behind this and I
have 20 30 whatever percent behind us
you know I feel very confident in my
ability to decode an entrepreneur and a
business model very quickly and so two
things run through my mind one should I
ever consider getting a little deeper in
that space you know I you know a lot of
people know me for what I am out here
and I have nourished people that know me
a little deeper a lot of the people that
I've been lucky enough to invest or
bison one thing I don't think a lot of
people know is a very deep product kyra
guy right growing up in retail I my
retail store was my product I thought
about end caps and what to put at the
register so inversion and color schemes
and copy so it was interesting 24 car
wanted me in tumblr because
wanted me for my product thoughts I mean
that's nuts like nobody would believe
that here and so I have a very good
reputation with some of the best
companies in the world for that product
stuff which they want the promotion of
the marketing some of the biz dev but
I'm able to get into deals that maybe
they wouldn't look like it would be able
to get into and so I may want to take
advantage of that as far as what to
invest in you know I'm a big believer
you bet on the jockey I'm very big on
who the entrepreneur is if you know
staunch floors will pivot seven times of
win if they got that stomach I mean it
there's a couple of gals reach the way
that I've invested in it's really just
lately I've been investing at more
females with them business grand street
a couple of other things that I just
know that they're not going to allow
like there's just no shot of losing
right and there's entrepreneurs like out
out there that they don't back to me
selling chickens I would only do that if
I thought that was the best use of my
time and the money and the opportunity
and so yeah I like to been a jockey so I
don't really it's not like oh I want
mobile or I want ecommerce you know I
want people that I think can kill it and
if they could explain it to me what
they're doing and I understand that
there's a market in need or opportunity
I'll bet